bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous sur
vous retrouver pour une nouvelle semaine
de sens public si vous découvrez ou
redécouvrez les missions à l'occasion de
cette rentrée je vous rappelle le rendez
vous tous les jours du lundi au jeudi à
18h et 22h 90 minutes de débat de
reportages et des expertises pour donner
du sens à l'actualité justement on sera
pour commencer en pleine actu
ukrainienne l'armée a repris en tout
trois mille cinq cents kilomètres carrés
aux russes ces derniers jours notamment
la ville stratégique 10e que pèse ce
succès militaires le pouvoir de vladimir
poutine est il fragilisé comment le
président russe utilise-t-il la menace
nucléaire on en débat juste après ses
titres et puis alors que le procès en
appel des attentats de charlie hebdo
montrouge et de l'hyper cacher s'est
ouvert aujourd'hui à paris nos experts
et notamment l'ancien juge
antiterroriste marc trévidic viendront
évaluer l'état de la menace islamiste en
france on se demandera notamment comment
surveiller les centaines de détenus qui
ont purgé leur peine et ont été libérés
ces deux dernières années mais d'abord
donc les détails de cette
contre-offensive ukrainienne avec quant
à un calme est
en un week end la carte du conflit
ukrainiens étaient redessinées
depuis 48 heures les forces militaires
et les responsables politiques
ukrainiens parle d'importants succès sur
le terrain et face aux troupes russes
des victoires dont le rythme s'est même
accélérée dimanche
zamenhof bobo au cours des dernières 24
heures les forces ukrainiennes ont
réussi à chasser l'ennemi de plus de 20
localités des mesures sont prises pour
les stabiliser et les placer sous
contrôle total
ce sont au total plus de 3000 kilomètres
carrés qui ont été repris à la russie
depuis début septembre d'après
l'état-major ukrainien l'avancée la plus
remarquable se trouve dans la région de
kharkiv la conquête 10 youm apparaît
comme un symbole dans cette ville et
stratégiques im des combats très
acharnée pour le contrôle de l'inde où
c'était l'un des objectifs stratégiques
des russes parce que c'est un énorme 9
ferroviaire et donc les contacts avec la
fédération russie les livraisons d'armes
etc
on voit des militaires sur le terrain de
l'ukraine c'est un passé aussi par le
contrôle de cette ville d'où son
importance
pour l'ukraine aussi à la clé ces
impressionnantes images de chars et
camions russe carbonisé une progression
militaire qui pourrait avoir des
conséquences importantes sur le moral
des troupes russes selon les services de
renseignement britanniques la confiance
des troupes déployées sur le terrain
envers leur hiérarchie risque
certainement de se détériorer encore
davantage le ministère russe de la
défense a reconnu ce week end avoir cédé
du terrain dans deux régions d'ukraine
yen mais sans reconnaître de déroute
militaire pour atteindre les objectifs
de l'opération militaire spécial de
libération du dombass il a été décidé de
regrouper les forces russes déployés
dans les régions de ballack l'ia et 10
yum afin de renforcer les efforts le
long du front de donetsk en poste
plusieurs régions ukrainiennes ont subi
des frappes aériennes russes dans la
soirée de dimanche privant même
d'électricité la région de kharkiv
pendant plusieurs heures le kremlin a
martelé ce lundi que l'offensive russe
continuera jusqu'à ce que je cite les
objectifs soient atteints excluant toute
perspective de négociations entre moscou
et kiev et pour évaluer l'importance de
cette contre-offensive j'accueille et
christine du moins clément bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes chercheuse associée
à la chaire risque de l'institut
d'administration des entreprises de
l'université paris 1 panthéon sorbonne
et chercheuse au centre de recherche de
l'école des officiers de la gendarmerie
nationale patricia allemonière bonsoir
patricia vous êtes grand reporter
spécialisé relations internationales
j'accueille également christian makarian
bonsoir du christian éditorialistes
internationale au point et à radio
classique et matthieu croissandeau
éditorialiste politique bonsoir on soit
mathieu alors je redonne ce chiffre pour
commencer même s'il est difficile à
vérifier trois 3500 kilomètres carrés
repris par l'armée ukrainienne a écrit
si nous un clément alors ça représente
on a cherché une petite partie des cent
vingt mille kilomètres carrés qui
étaient soit contrôlée déjà avant le 24
février ou qui ont été repris par
l'armée russe depuis trois mille cinq
cent kilomètres c'est relativement peu
mais c'est pas seulement symbolique
pourquoi alors c'est pas seulement
symbolique parce que déjà c'est sur
plusieurs sites différents
on a parlé de toute la région de rare
qu'yves au nord mais aussi sur la région
de kherson et vous avez deux points qui
sont extrêmement importants qui sont
stratégiques et ça démontre aussi une
faiblesse russe qu'il va bien falloir
essayer de justifier non vous en parliez
dans le reportage le ministère de la
défense a reconnu avoir quelques pertes
mais ce qui est aussi intéressant c'est
quand on regarde le traitement
médiatique qui est fait ou on s'aperçoit
qu'il ya un peu comme un espèce d'effet
de saisissement où on n'a pas encore
élaboré un espèce de plans pour essayer
de faire tourner et on n'en a pas trouvé
les éléments de langage encore on voit
qu'il ya un petit peu ce principe là et
puis le deuxième point c'est que il est
assez difficile d'arriver à trouver un
discours positif sur des éléments
factuels qui sont très faciles à trouver
et ça c'est assez intéressant notamment
parce que ça peut montrer qu'on a
quelque part finalement une relative
crise politique ou au moins une pression
politique dans la mesure où au niveau
des médias quand on regarde les gros
médias à la gazzetta qui essaye de
donner des éléments positifs en faisant
croire que ses lecteurs sont à trop
capable de regarder une carte parce que
notamment ils parlent d'une
opération qui a été réalisée par un
hélicoptère sauf que la ville où il
positionne cette action donc qui aurait
repoussé les forces ukrainienne elle est
très très loin dans les territoires
occupés par la russie jusqu alors donc
sauf à dire qu'on n'a pas ouvert une
carte pour montrer à quel point on était
très fort on a ces éléments là donc on
voit qu'il ya quand même un petit peu un
mouvement de pédalage aidera pour
rattraper si vous voulez d'un point de
vue dire sur snes cursive ce que l'on a
puis un deuxième argumentaire qui
sortent qui est qui permet d'expliquer
que finalement si la russie a perdu du
terrain ce n'est pas forcément que face
aux ukrainiens qui ne sont pas si bons
que ça puisqu'on va vous parler d'une
rhétorique on avait déjà vu en 2014 qui
est l'armé de l'otan donc on va vous
expliquer finalement que ce sont des
forces étrangères donc non ukrainienne
qui sont sur le terrain et compris
otanienne voir ethniquement différents
tant qu' on essaie pas forcément face à
l'ukraine compères mais parce que les
occidentaux et l'otan sont à la
manoeuvre alors j'aimerais qu'on analyse
peut-être cette cette percée elle même
si quelques comment on peut l'expliquer
cette percée alors j'imagine que les
armes
promise annoncés sont enfin arrivés en
masse ils restent là forcément cet
argument là mais comme on l'expliquait
il ya plusieurs ya plusieurs facteurs il
ya effectivement comme vous dites
l'arrivée en masse des armes qui étaient
qui ont fini par arriver américaine la
dea américaine est colossal
c'est beaucoup plus que ce qu'ils ont
donné à israël à l'egypte durant en 2020
c'est on peut même pas s'imaginer
effectivement cette aide je crois 40
milliards enfin elle et devint
officiellement et en fait tout le monde
estime qu'elle est double alors donc il
ya cette aide massive qui arrive et puis
une stratégie qui était menée par les
forces du crânienne très habile qui a
bénéficié du soutien de tous les sets
des services de renseignement américains
pour effectivement faire ce qu'on
appelle c'est presqu'une une guerre
éclair c'est peut-être une offensive
éclair face à fait penser aux offensives
dans le désert voyez des ddd des forces
par exemple je pense aux forces
canadiennes ou à d'autres qui font c'est
comme ça sur les forces de kadhafi qui
étaient avec leur gros tank et qui
étaient empêtrés dans le sable ont
menacé c'est un peu assez un peu de
septembre troisième élément c'est que la
russie est tombé dans le piège un peu
tendu par les russes qui leur avait dit
mi temps mais c'est carson qui nous
intéresse la basse et c'est le sud on
veut regagner cette cette partie là il
ya bien une petite offensive grignotage
en cours mais les forces russes se sont
toutes arrivées en particulier unités
pratiquement des forces spéciales russes
13 compétentes qui est arrivé qui s'est
positionné là et qu'elle complètement
dégarni d'ailleurs et qui a complètement
dégarni ce front et puis enfin ces
messieurs avec une yz et vans étaient
tous à l'est en train de blablater de
faire des grands exercices et d'assister
des exercices militaires pas du tout
concerné par ce qui se passait sur le
terrain donc il ya une convergence
d'éléments qui en fait que les
ukrainiens ont
remporter et là on arrive un peu à ce
qu'on appelle en stratégie mais je parle
un peu sous le point oméga c'est-à-dire
ce fameux point où claque ça peut
basculer c'est une vraie question de ce
débat est ce que c'est un point s p
s'est alors il est très difficile de
répondre c'est le point qui produit la
dislocation c'est à dire qu'à un moment
comme un élastique est trop tendue ça
casse parce que tu joues au niveau
logistique vous n'arrivez plus à
alimenter il faut rappeler à mon avis
instant de données assez simple à
mémoriser l'ensemble du front étaient
défendues par les russes représente 2000
km il décide voilà et c'est considérable
donc il y a toujours que 140 à 160 mille
hommes qui ont été envoyées depuis le
départ on n'est toujours pas passée en
conscription même si on va chercher même
dans les prisons certains volontaires
avec des soldats améliorer et augmenter
sa ne produira pas d effet de masse donc
l'armée russe est toujours responsable
de son propre échec si je puis dire en
tout cas les pays arc de l'armée les
généraux et puis il y a une énorme
apparition que l'on connaissait du point
de vue des militaires qui est les
déficits
traditionnel des russes en matière de
logistique ils ne savent pas faire cela
c'est la logistique sa relève énormément
des règles de l'économie de marché c'est
un peu vous savez le kaiser guillaume 2
a eu l'idée du montage du démontage des
pontes of local en renvoyant le cirque
barnum démonter remonter d'une ville à
l'autre le cirque c'est anecdotique mais
c'est très sportif les russes sont
mauvais en matière logistique et les
zones qui sont reprises ces cinq sens
inverse ou logistique ce sont des
verrous et il ya surtout copiale ce qui
est très important ce que c'est un et
ferroviaires comme l'a dit yacaman tout
à l'heure mais c'est aussi un lieu où on
était concentré des moyens logistiques
considérables et énormément de munitions
et puis du raisin des réserves de
carburant donc le fait que les
ukrainiens prennent ça c'est non
seulement la route nord-sud et la route
est ouest pour aller à kharkiv qui est
coupée mais c'est une sorte de capuchon
détenus maintenant par les ukrainiens
qui couvre au nord les deux oblath du
lou anne sonnet de dio nièce qu alors
qu'en descendant very very few on arrive
quasiment à enrober si je puis dire les
forces russes dont c'est vraiment un
revers à robert sérieux qui suivant les
russes mais vous dit peut-être pas le
point de le pour le point de bascule sur
les chaînes j'attends de voir parce que
les quoi qu'il en soit l'armée russe
demeure très super en termes de matériel
en termes d'hommes et d'effectifs même
si tout le monde est fatigué démoralisés
s'ils ont perdu un matériel considérable
et encore durant les trois derniers
jours il reste la mary serait-ce quand
même masse en termes de masse supérieure
de loin à la main mais je termine sur un
poêle à l'ukrainienne a marqué un point
tout à fait essentiel grâce à l'armement
américain ce sont les rails mars parce
que ce sont des lance-roquettes
multiples dont la portée de 80 km bridée
par les américains parce qu'ils peuvent
aller jusqu'à 300 km d'américains n'ont
pas livré les
missiles qui vont les obus qui vont a eu
à 300 kilomètres mais 80 km est la
caractéristique des ukrainiens c'est qui
frappe la ligne de front plus en même ça
la ligne à l'arrière la ligne en
profondeur donc ce qui fait que des
manières les forces russes sont prises
en sandwich la ligne de front déguste
aux premières loges et à l'arrière et
ils sont bombardés également donc il ya
quand même une tactique ukrainienne à
mon avis largement inspirée par les
états unis largement puisque encore une
fois et je termine monsieur blinken
qu'était la vie à deux jours a dit
jusqu'à ce que moi je trouve classement
assez choquant nous avons remporté une
victoire nous et c'est à nous je vous le
dirais tant d'états américains
évidemment je vous redonne la parole
tout de suite mais je voudrais qu'on
entendait des réactions de d'ukrainiens
et du chrétiennes qui ont été
béret qui ont retrouvé leurs soldats
évidemment il ya beaucoup d'émotions
parfois ils ont ils ont du mal à trouver
leurs mots regardez moi c'était ça va
saigner nous avons rencontré les
premiers dans les véhicules blindés nous
avons parlé avec eux et nous avons eu
les larmes aux yeux nous étions si
heureux que nos garçons soient venus ils
ont fait un excellent travail si
rapidement nous ne nous attendions pas à
ce que soient si rapides
aujourd'hui dans la matinée deux
véhicules sont arrivés dans la rue où
nous vivons nous sommes allés à leur
rencontre les larmes aux yeux nous les
attendions on ne pouvait pas imaginer
qu'il viendrait de façon aussi
inattendue on les attend depuis près de
six mois on est tellement heureux
hier matin il y avait des russes ce
matin déjà des ukrainiens dire que je
suis heureux n'est pas suffisant je n'ai
pas de mots pour m'exprimer
et christine du moins clément ces images
ces témoignages
ils sont moi j'ai le sentiment qu'ils
sont aussi important pour nous pour les
opinions publiques occidentales
pour l'europe et les états unis quand
voit justement des armes à l'ukraine
qu'il faut donner des des signes
positifs à ses opinions le temps est
extrêmement important pour les deux
parties du côté de la russie on essaye
de d'attendre l'hiver en fête et de
pouvoir bénéficier de l'hiver en
espérant que ça va compliquer l'avancé
ukrainienne et leur permettre de figer
quelque part leur position et que
l'hiver venant et le gaz augmente en
plus les populations occidentales
pouvant un petit peu se fatiguer du
conflit ukrainien lieu d'inflation et
bien qu'on arriverait à quelque part un
peu figé la décision occidentale et
affaiblir le soutien ukrainien donc on a
un peu ce calcul la d'usure de temps si
on pouvait lever les sanctions qui
faciliterait le soutien économique de
l'effort de l'opération spéciale puisque
c'est pas une guerre ça serait très bien
et côté ukrainien on est l inverse on va
essayer au contraire d'avancé le propose
il est impossible voilà dans un temps
restreint et de montrer aussi aux
occidentaux de parler victoire que le
soutien et efficace et qu'il faut
maintenir ce soutien tant financier que
stratégique puisqu'on parle
effectivement du partage de
renseignements et aussi au niveau du
matériel donc on assez on a ces deux
jeux là est peut-être pour revenir
rapidement sur ce que vous lisiez il ya
un travail des ukrainiens qui est fait
de mai depuis un peu avant l'offensive
d'aller attaquer tous les points
logistique tout ce qui va être en termes
de dépôts de carburant de munitions mais
aussi de communication et
télécommunication pour essayer de
bloquer et de compliquer toute
réorganisation aux militaires voire un
tour repli autrement que dans un
mouvement de relative panique ce que
l'on a pu ce que l'on a pu observer dans
différentes vidéos donc il ya cette
liasse alias double travail là qui a été
fait et puis cette désorganisation là
aura très probablement facilité
notamment l'avancée dans la région
parquet laquelle à la stratégie de
l'armée ukrainienne voilà ce dont on
parle dans ce premier débat de science
publique et regardez je propose un
élément ce que déclare le ministre de la
défense l'ukrainien oleksiy reznikoff
c'était dans le monde aujourd'hui alors
oui pardon c'est pas un seul tort c'est
moi qui dois lire la première étape dans
la guerre visait à dissuader les russes
la deuxième a consisté à établir un
équilibre entre eux et nous sur le front
à stabiliser le front à tester leur
capacité de résilience la campagne de
qautre enfance iv la troisième étape
patricia allemonière vouliez mettre en
avant un élément intéressant sur cette
stratégie c'est la relative autonomie
des commandements locaux c'est une armée
assez décentralisé c'est que oui c'est
ce qui a fait toute sa force d'ailleurs
au départ parce que l inverse de leur
mire et de l'armée russe qui était
complètement monolithique gens me dire
qu'il composait comme un bloc et bien
l'armée ukrainienne y avait une grande
indépendance des commandements locaux ce
qui a fait que quand les l'offensive
russe s'est faite et bien chaque
commandant à son niveau bien sûr en en
référant à ces responsables mais avait
une autonomie et et ça moi qui ai suivi
et l'armée française et l'armée
américaine parfois sur le terrain je me
suis aperçu qu'il y avait une plus
grande autonomie aussi chez les
américains dans l'est dans les dents les
la façon de g et la situation locale il
s'en réfère toujours alors responsable
mais le commandant local est là en
ukraine c'est manifeste s'est manifesté
et donc ça peut être un atout dans les
opérations qui sont menées en
particulier dans le sud je pense plutôt
à kherson à à ce niveau là il ya un
élément dans le dans le reportage de
quentin calme mais qui était aussi très
intéressant je voudrais bien vous
entendre là dessus christian c'est
l'état des troupes russes et peut-être
le fait que cette contre-offensive
craignent n allait accroître une forme
de défiance des soldats russes david
leur hiérarchie est ce que bon alors si
malines sont les services secrets ou qui
fournit ces informations est ce qu'on
doit les prendre avec des pincettes je
ne sais pas mais quels éléments on a
pour accréditer à nice alors on peut en
déduire une très forte démoralisation
des forces russes les forces russes
perdent le moral parce que leur chef
contesté et il voit on abordera
peut-être la contestation du pouvoir
politique on va éviter un autre sujet
mais les chefs sont contestés après une
première vague n'oublions pas il y a
plus de trois mois et il ya plus de deux
mois pardon que 29 août il avait limogé
plusieurs généraux donc visiblement ça
ne marche pas et ça ne marche pas parce
que c'est une armée qui repose sur un
cercle d'officiers qui traitent très
durement les hommes et la strate par
exemple forte de l'armée française qui
est constitué par les sous-officiers et
très faible traditionnellement dans la
mêlée blanc en nombre vous en nombre et
égalité peut-être et en qualité aussi or
le sous-officier et celui qui est au
contact des hommes et qui fluidifie les
choses il y a énormément de dureté
imposer à l'homme combattants russes qui
est mal traitée au niveau des rations
de la nourriture beaucoup ont manqué
d'eau le carburant arrive d'ici demain
je l'évoquais tout à l'heure mais il ya
une condition du soldat qui est
traditionnellement terriblement dur
c'est les ukrainiens on le voit à
l'écran sont infiniment mieux équipés
par les américains bien sûr et les
britanniques mais il y à il ya quand
même un gap et je pense que pas d'enjeu
termine là l'armée russe subi une forte
démoralisation et ça ça compte
énormément
à moins de mathieu est ensuite passé au
delà de cette démoralisation est ce que
les soldats russes comprennent
l'objectif stratégique de guerre dans
impression qu'il a changé de côté russe
et aujourd'hui qu'elle est si les est-ce
qu'il ya les prix alors patrice et à la
manière qu'ils ont à dire ça il ya très
peu de soldats d' au niveau de la base
russe au sens où l'entend c'est à dire
qu'il ya très peu de gens qui viennent
de la partie ouest de l'oural quand même
drôle on ya pas de de gens de moscou
pratiquement pas de gens de saint
pétersbourg la cette armée est composée
à plus de 40% de deux soldats venus des
républiques à la marge et est donc ces
gens là ils sont parfois quitterait de
la prison il ya une ong très récemment
nous a appris que s'ils voulaient pas
combattre il fallait qu'il peine 8000
euros pour échapper
donc vous voyez c'est des gens qui
viennent de ces républicains donc la
situation est excessivement difficile
sont des gens qui effectivement ne sont
pas en plus n'ont pas la compétence et
quand vous voyez que quelques agents
fini la corvée sam kadirov le patron de
la tchétchénie qui envoyait un maximum
de deux soldats sur le terrain est en
train de dénoncer la stratégie militaire
russe vous vous dites que parce qu'il
pourquoi delà des nombreux à ce qu'il
veut et ses hommes se font trop tué et j
c'est quoi aujourd'hui l'objectif
stratégique de guerre russe ce qu'on
peut dire
clément a laissé peut-être deux points
il ya eu un réajustement perpétuelle des
objectifs militaires russes depuis le
début c'est à dire que on va fluctuer au
fur et à mesure des avancées ou des
déconfitures sur le terrain pour essayer
d'avoir un réajustement et pour pouvoir
transformer cette opération spéciale
militaire en une victoire ou en une non
défaite politique donc on est parti de
quelque chose de assez flou mais
relativement maximaliste on se rappelle
un démilitarisé des nazifié faire tomber
le gouvernement a finalement asphyxier
économiquement l'ukraine et libérer les
populations opprimées et sous l'égide de
sites dans de basses donc on a déjà
commencé à redire bien vous avez tous
les guillemets oui mais quand on recule
c'est vraiment c'est l'art et aux
employés c'est ce que vous avez dans le
discours officiel donc on a eu cette
limitation là à l'heure actuelle on est
dans un enjeu un petit peu entre les
deux il ya eu des déclarations qui ont
été faits notamment pour réciter
monsieur choi bourdon qui est le
ministre de la défense le 24 août qui
disait que la russie avait limité ses
attaques pour protéger finalement les
populations civiles donc on essaye de
retrouver un petit peu des argumentaires
pour justifier on peut en douter là
dessus et peut-être sur la conscription
il ya plusieurs choses c'est que ils ont
expliqué que le nom vers plus de
conscrits sur la ligne ce qui a un petit
peu de limites et donc on est sur des
engagements volontaires est
effectivement venant pour une très large
part de minorités ethniques et dans
plusieurs cadres alors ya les unités
dites unités volontaire où on a recruté
y compris dans les prisons pour des
sommes plus ou moins intéressantes mais
pour des formats courts en règle
générale c'est sur des périodes de six
mois et qui coûte très cher quand on les
paye puisque ce sont des salaires qui
sont importants plus des primes mais au
niveau de ses minorités ethniques vous
avez aussi des gens qui peuvent croire
que ça va être un ascendant social en
prenant l'exemple de choïgou par exemple
et puis vous avez aussi tous ceux qui
n'ont pas les moyens de s'enfuir quand
vous disiez que finalement c'est le prix
pour échapper à la conscription là
encore faire la fête au départ mais moi
je vous entends additionnel je vous
entends les autres mais
pourquoi ils sont encore là pourquoi ils
ont pas déjà perdu la guerre voyez ce
que je veux dire s'ils sont aussi
sordide être un peu triviale domicile
avait un effet de masse qui continue à
jouer et que la stratégie qui a été
choisi dans le tente et +2 après la
découverte que kiev ne tombait pas et
qu'il fallait tout rabattre sur l'est
1,7 ceux tentés +2 a consisté à écraser
les villes et assure employé
l'artillerie en utilisant en moyenne 60
milles au but par jour il faut
l'alimenter une force pareil donc c'est
ça qui la pose problème aujourd'hui mais
je reviens sur la composition de l'armée
russe c'est tout à fait exact ce qui
était dit par patriciens comme par
christine simplement voilà jusqu'ici ça
ne posait pas un problème parce qu'il
s'agissait en 2008 d'écraser la géorgie
il y avait des bouriatte decho vaches
des daguestanais et c'est bon le chef
choïgou et tout va donc il est supérieur
à 7 en sibérie du sud donc c'est un
homme donc ça cadrait fit ascendance
asiatiques il a une autre
caractéristique qui est intéressante il
a jamais fait d'armé de d'expo il aucune
expérience militaire et c'est voilà
c'est un spécialiste des incendies des
situations d'urgence civil et en
uniforme quand ils se hissent exhibe il
est couvert de médailles donc il ya un
côté tapioca dans tout ça qui est un peu
je dirais ça commence mal à ce niveau là
le type qui est retail et comme on dit
en langage militaire s'est guère asimov
le général kir asimov mais j'ai un gars
asimov toute évidence qui fut un des
héros de la guerre de tchétchénie est
fatigué et n'a plus la main donc il ya
quand même énormément de problèmes dans
ce système là allez la main moi je la
reprendre parlons de migrants de
christian parce qu'il ya encore beaucoup
de thèmes à aborder dans ce débat qui
est passionnant
peut-être sur le la durée de cette
guerre mathieu et son impact sur les
opinions publiques occidentales et
notamment françaises il ya il ya
plusieurs axes en pacifiste qui
s'exprime depuis le 24 février et qui
continue de s'exprimer en fruits depuis
le déclenchement d'invasion de l'ukraine
en entendu plusieurs responsables
politiques français qui n'ont cranbrook
la paix à la bouche ce qui est louable
sur le papier mais leur pacifisme eux et
quand même pas dénués d'arrière pensées
et pour le coup derrière ce noble
objectif ya des intentions les arguments
un peu moins louables pour le coup cela
le premier repose sur la nécessité d'une
prétendue neutralité ou plutôt d'un
alignement
de la france ça c'est un argument qu on
a beaucoup entendu par la campagne
présidentielle notamment à gauche et
notamment chez jean luc mélenchon ont
celui-ci dénoncé le parti des lattes en
guerre et s'opposer par exemple à la
livraison d'armes à l'ukraine c'est une
position qui revient en croit pas se
mouiller en renvoyant dos à dos
l'agresseur et l'agressé le premier pour
son bellicisme le second parce qu'ils
l'auraient bien cherché c'est ce qu'on
entendait aussi à l'époque j'aurais en
gros des de chaque côté ce
serait pour moi grande contre-propagande
ça vous dit quelque chose c'est quelque
chose qu'on a entendu et une semaine
dans la bouche de de ségolène royal qui
n'a pas dit autre chose en mettant en
doute les crimes de guerre en ukraine qu
elles qualifiées de propagande de la
peur du régime ukrainien en ne faisant
que du coup reprendre la propagande
russe le second argument que que
brandissent nos pacifiste c'est le
risque d' escalade alors là pour le coup
c'est henri guaino par exemple ancienne
plume de nicolas sarkozy qui après avoir
vigoureusement dénoncé en mai dernier
cette france de somnambules enfin cet
occident de somnambules qu'ils
marcheraient vers la guerre en remet une
couche cette semaine dans l'express en
s'en prenant à ce qu'il qualifie de 2
jusqu'au boutiste le jusqu'au boutisme
envahi les esprits mais pour aller au
bout de quoi qu'y at il au bout du bout
la guerre jusqu'au dernier l'ukrainien
la guerre jusqu'aux derniers russ la
guerre jusqu'à la ruine de l'europe
jusqu'au dernier européen la guerre
mondiale la guerre froide la guerre
nucléaire vous remarquerez qui a qu'une
seule hypothèse qu'une formule pas henri
guaino c'est la guerre jusqu à
l'intégrité retrouver des frontières et
peut-être la guerre jusqu'à la paix et
puis aussi la question des sanctions oui
ça c'est le troisième argument favori de
nos pacifiste c'est l'inefficacité des
sanctions européennes contre la russie
si inefficace voir ci contre productif
pour le peuple français qui conviendrait
de les lever au plus tôt et évidemment
au plus vite ça c'est ce que vous
entendez par exemple chez marine le pen
ou chez ségolène royal décidément encore
elle pourquoi les sanctions ont été mal
évalués mal anticipé et se retourne
contre nous c'est un refrain qui en un
rappel d'autres notamment au siècle
dernier oui le pacifisme de
l'entre-deux-guerres oui parce que le
point commun de tous ces pacifistes
solistes de tous bords c'est que
derrière tous ces appels à la paix se
cache au fond une forme de capitulation
devant un état de fait parce que faire
là et aujourd'hui avec quelqu'un qui a
envahi un autre pays bas ça revient à
accepter une certaine façon qu'ils les
envahir il forme de pouce au point de
vue que reprendre un air bien connu
entonné dans les années 30 au siècle
dernier ces gains ne sont pas les nôtres
pour vivre heureux vivons planquez vous
souvenez à l'époque la question avait
été fracturé la gauche sur la guerre en
espagne avec la france de léon blum puis
daladier qui avait finalement décidé de
ne pas intervenir ce avait fracturé les
démocraties occidentales aussi enfin pas
tellement fracture il parce qu'ils
étaient tous d'accord face à la montée
de l'hégémonisme hitlérien en gros qui a
abouti à la crise de confiance de munich
on se rappelle que quatre pays entre 36
et 38 ont perdu leur indépendance en
l'ethiopie l'autriche l'albanie la
tchécoslovaquie sans qu' aucune
démocratie à l'époque dite libérale ne
trouve quelque chose à dire ou à faire
au fond au nom du pacifisme des
démocraties de l'époque semblait
démissionner face aux états autoritaires
il faudrait peut-être rappeler à nos
pacifiste d'aujourd'hui que oublier que
la nécessaire et inlassable recherche de
la paix
ne doit pas enfin il ne faut pas oublier
je pense que c'est nécessaire il a sabré
charge à peine n'est pas un lâche
laisser faire merci mathieu je voudrais
rebondir sur les sanctions dont vous
parlez où les critiques contre cette
sanction la crise nous a tellement
imaginantes là que la france renonce aux
sanctions est ce que ça pourrait
pénaliser notre pays
l'enjeu il est je pense qu'ils les
multiples déjà peut-être faut rappeler
que les sanctions à la base ont été
prises pour
compliquer la capacité de la russie à
maintenir son effort militaire on sait
pertinemment que des sanctions seules ne
sont pas suffisantes mais sont néanmoins
nécessaires c'est dans un ensemble et on
sait aussi que ça va prendre du temps
avant d'être efficace puisqu'il y à une
latence il ya une capacité finalement
d'absorption alors qui peut varier d'un
état à un autre et puis en fonction des
sanctions qu'on va prendre avant d'avoir
un effet là on commence à avoir l'effet
de ces sanctions en russie on commence à
le sentir à plusieurs niveaux et c'est
peut-être pas forcément un hasard si on
entend encore plus de voix maintenant
qu'ils demandent de les lever rapidement
alors qu'elle commence justement à faire
effet rappelé on est toujours un peu
dans cette danse est en jeu deux
temporalités ou fissurées les
occidentaux et les soutiens à l'ukraine
et essayer de regagner un petit peu de
marge de manoeuvre serait tout un
avantage de la russie qui à l'heure
actuelle à quelque chose comme 80 7
millions de dollars de creux dans ses
réserves de change qui a à peu près 20 %
de pertes sur ses marchés intérieurs ce
qui est assez énorme et qui a énormément
d'entreprises étrangères qui sont partis
alors certaines ont fait on a eu un
petit peu d effet par exemple starbucks
qui a été repris par un rappeur très
connu en faisant en expliquant que tout
allait mieux dans la réalité défier ces
entreprises représentait une part non
négligeable du pib et c'est un petit peu
comme si la russie avait rayé d'un trait
de plume un gros pourcentage de ces
investissements directs étrangers des
dix dernières années donc on voit que là
il ya un véritable intérêt cela dit
maintenant on est dans un effet où on a
essayé de commencer à faire des pubs on
le voit notamment sur les enjeux
énergétiques où on essaye de trouver
d'autres fournisseurs ce qui va être
compliqué pour des pays qui sont
particulièrement dépendants type
l'allemagne mais il faut savoir où on
veut aller aussi vous êtes dans quelque
part dans un principe de rapport de
force la russie et dans un espèce de
rapport de force si vous voulez chez ce
rapport de force là vous perdez et
quelque part bas on continue de gagner
donc on a un petit peu cette cet enjeu
là mais il faut il et puis la france
furent un risque d'isolement et on veut
tout dire au niveau de l'union
européenne dont les versions il faut
dire une vérité qui est dérangeante pour
les occidentaux c'est que les sanctions
économiques compenser ce qu'on ne
pouvait pas faire sur plan militaire
puisque nous n'avions pas les forces
conventionnelles
suffisante pour aider davantage la rue
et craignent elles et que dans le cas
français il ya même eu un petit
démarrage à froid sur l'aide militaire
faut quand même le dire on a pris un
certain temps ensuite c'est
irréprochable la français est aligné
complètement sur le soutien à l'ukraine
mais ces sanctions
qu'on pensait d'ailleurs c'est un gros
des mac à lui aux etats unis le était
supposé de compenser parce que c'est
exactement ce que l'union européenne qui
fondamentalement une entité économique
sait faire le mieux des sanctions
économiques donc et ça a été
objectivement ça n'a pas été raté il
faut arrêter de dire ça et il ya
beaucoup de vérités qui sont bonnes à
rappeler sur les sanctions quand
monsieur poutine dit dans la
conversation qu'il a eue la dernière il
ya deux jours avec emmanuel macron
lever les sanctions sur
la l'exportation des denrées
alimentaires
c'est scandaleux car il n'y a pas de
sanctions européennes sur les denrées
alimentaires il ya des sanctions sur les
paiements bancaires
de toute forme de denrées y compris les
denrées alimentaires s'est pas du tout
la même chose dit poutine qui est assez
pervers sur ce point veut qu'on lève le
système bancaire qu'ils étouffent
il ya beaucoup de choses à dire alors il
est exact que la hausse du prix du
pétrole et du gaz due à sa raréfaction à
la raréfaction des livraisons disent
décidés par la russie a fait monter le
les excédents commerciaux russe oui de
façon spectaculaire qui à leur tour ces
accès dans le commerciaux russes
soutiennent le rouble qui se trouve
assez haut mais tout cela est factice et
temporaire c factice on pourrait se dire
il ya part dieu les ors de guerre en
quelque sorte les moyens de financer
cette bière pendant encore combien parce
que la sous-secrétaire d'état par
exemple américaine y en a plusieurs
blinken là plusieurs adjoints une
d'entre elles ap une déclaration très
claire avec photos à l'appui à
washington montrant que des composants
électroniques de machine à laver le
linge avait été utilisé dans du matériel
pour déclencher notamment les les
missiles etc
les états c'est pourquoi la ccan même
bon si il vont manquer le composant les
russes très rapidement et ça va peser
encore une fois sur le résultat
militaire on va dans dans le cadre des
sanctions il ya forcément la question du
pouvoir de vladimir poutine et on va y
venir mais j'aurais quand même vous
entendent aussi patricia ski évoqué
mathieu ce qui est intéressant c'est le
l'impact d'une du d'une guerre qui qui
dure on est à six mois et demi sur les
opinions publiques européennes
occidentales s'est pas totalement neutre
plus elle dure plus c'est peut-être
difficile de l'accepter qu'est ce que
vous en pensez moi je crois que il ya eu
un temps où c'était difficile je dirais
de ça il ya un peu avant l'été
paradoxalement et je crois que
maintenant les gens sont rentrés dans
une autre logique dans la logique il ya
eu la guerre en ukraine may et avant
aussi puisqu'on ne cesse de répéter que
c'est pas seulement la guerre en ukraine
c'est tout et donc que les ils sont
rentrés dans une logique très économies
économies que faire mais pas tant ce
reporter est
accusé l'ukraine mise à part certains
mouvements partis politiques le net
c'est je crois que l'opinion publique ne
va pas tendu j'ai que ça que les que les
pourcentages sont stabilisés en revanche
je partage complètement les idées sur
les sanctions vont mordre à terme est
beaucoup plus grave en russie 1
j'entends un mais beaucoup plus graves
pour la russie c'est sa dépendance
accrue vis-à-vis de la chine parce que
si aujourd'hui la russie ne peut pas
envoyer du pétrole en chine autant
qu'elles le voudraient et du gaz parce
qu'encore ont construit pas des gazoducs
et des tuyaux aussi facilement que ça et
qu'elle est obligée de brûler
aujourd'hui ces gaz c'est à dire
qu'elles polluent l'atmosphère en
brûlant le gaz qu'elle ne veut pas nous
envoyer mais plus grave je crois que
c'est la chine qui propre qui profitent
de cette de ce retournement de la russie
qui achètent des usines qui prend des
actions que ça mais la russie a mis la
main dans la main de la jeunesse et la
russie va être va rentrer en dépendance
totale selon moi et ne sera plus qu'une
colonie atteint me chinoise si des
mesures ne sont pas prises évidemment
c'est logique c'est logique ce serait
une cologne veulent a dit mir poutine
aura abouti à mettre son pas mettre son
pays en dépendance vis à vis de la
chimie en faire une colonie chinoise
alors le pouvoir de lugnorre poutine il
repose notamment sur la peur du je
voudrais proposer un style jourdain de
nous rejoindre si on va parler
maintenant de soir steve de la plus
grande centrale nucléaire d'europe
évidemment sapori de chaque est la
situation sur place situation toujours
aussi inquiétants depuis hier dimanche
le dernier réacteur de la centrale est à
l'arrêt à l'heure où l'on parle donc les
six réacteurs de la plus grande centrale
nucléaire d'europe ne fonctionne plus
regardé ce communiqué publié hier par la
compagnie nationale de production
d'énergie nucléaire ukrainienne
aujourd'hui on septembre à 3h41 l'unité
numéro 6 de la centrale a été déconnecté
du réseau électrique en cas de nouveau
dommage pour les lignes de transmission
reliant le site au système électrique
les besoins internes devons être assurée
par les générateurs fonctionnant au
diesel générateurs dont la durée de vie
est limitée par la ressource
technologique et la quantité de gazole
disponible fin de citation le réacteur
qui a été désactivé et est depuis trois
jours le seul le seul à produire
l'électricité nécessaire au
fonctionnement au refroidissement du
combustible nucléaire et donc à la
sécurité du site une sécurité de plus en
plus difficile assure est homérique
cette annonce l'annnonce de la mise à
l'arrêt du dernier acteur ça a fait
réagir le président français oui à
l'initiative de l'elysée un entretien
téléphonique a eu lieu ce dimanche entre
emmanuel macron et vladimir poutine à
l'occasion de cet échange le président
français est revenu sur la situation
autour de la centrale alizée a publié
dans la foulée le communiqué qu'on va
voir le président de la république a
insisté sur la nécessité que la sûreté
de la centrale nucléaire de zaporijia
soit assurée il a rappelé que
l'occupation russe était la cause des
risques pesant aujourd'hui sur
l'intégrité de la centrale on retrouve
bien évidemment une autre version du
côté du kremlin thomas vladimir poutine
dénoncé les attaques de l'armée
ukrainienne sur la centrale on rappelle
que
le site est occupé par les forces russes
depuis le mois de mars qu'il est la
cible de frappes dont ukrainiens et
russes se renvoient la responsabilité
selon l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie atomique la situation sur
place est intenable mais il existe tout
de même une petite lueur d'espoir écouté
le directeur général de l'aeia c'était
cet après midi
ce dont nous avons besoin c'est que
l'ukraine et la russie se mettent
d'accord sur un principe très simple à
savoir ne pas attaquer ou ne pas
bombarder la centrale et nous pouvons
faire respecter cet accord de manière
très simple car nous avons des
observateurs sur place
ces dernières heures j'ai vu des signes
indiquant que les deux pays sont
intéressés par un accord a terminé en
rappelant que les as pourri déjà en
temps normal permet d'alimenter 4
millions de foyers qu'avec l'hiver la
situation va devenir de plus en plus
tendue pour beaucoup d'ukrainiens un
éventuel accord sur la centrale serait
donc une excellente nouvelle merci
beaucoup steve jourdain pour toutes ces
explications christine du moins clément
est ce que est ce qu'on peut y croire à
cet accord autour de la centrale alors
que c'est peut-être justement en ce
moment de l'année mercredi n'a besoin de
d'utiliser cette menace alors que ses
troupes ont perdu du terrain voyez ce
que je veux dire on peut utiliser la
négociation d'un accord au niveau de la
centrale d'une manière différente déjà
pour essayer de calmer un petit peu
l'offensive lire ben voilà on est dans
une négociation on peut pas être dans
une négociation alors que on est sous
les bombes donc on peut essayer un petit
peu de jouer la montre là dessus et de
toute façon ça sera la question ça
serait quelles seraient les termes
finalement de cet accord je doute fort
que la russie fasse un accord dans
lequel elle ne trouverait pas un
avantage certain voir un bénéfice et
puis le temps qui sera nécessaire pour
arriver à cet accord où finalement on
aurait une démilitarisation de la zone
si on prend en parallèle l'accord sur
les céréales sur l'export de céréales ça
a pris plusieurs mois pour réussir et y
arriver il est très probable qu'il soit
l'objet de renégociations prochainement
puisque des signaux indiquent que
finalement moscou ne trouvera pas
forcément son compte donc on a tous ces
enjeux-là qui vont pouvoir être être mis
en oeuvre ce que l'on voit c'est aussi
quand même l'utilisation d'une d'une
installation nucléaire civil à des fins
tactiques militaires et puis on voit
aussi qu'on a un saut de ligne de
manière assez régulière quand il a été
question notamment de
de d'arrêter de faire des visas pour les
populations et c'est bien vous avez la
porte parole du ministère des affaires
étrangères qui avait fait une
déclaration par les réseaux sociaux en
expliquant que si jamais il devait
advenir quoi que ce soit sur la centrale
de zappos ridja et bien les occidentaux
s'apercevrait que les radiations elles
n'avaient pas besoin de visa donc on est
toujours dans une espèce de de
négociation et de rhétorique contre les
uns et entre les autres qu'il y ait un
intérêt à ce qu'il y ait un accord
potentiellement oui mais sous quelle
forme et dans quelles et dans quelle
temporalité un dernier élément dans ceux
d'ordre dans ce débat une réaction celle
de la haute commissaire aux droits de
l'homme des nations unies qui
finalement redit ce que l'on sait sur la
réalité du pouvoir autocratique du
kremlin regarder
en russie les intimidations les mesures
restrictives et les sanctions à
l'encontre des personnes qui expriment
leur opposition à la guerre en ukraine
compromettent l'exercice des libertés
fondamentales garanties par la
constitution et notamment les droits à
la liberté de réunion d'expression et
d'association les pressions exercées sur
les journalistes le blocage des
ressources disponibles sur internet et
les autres formes de censure sont
incompatibles avec le pluralisme des
médias et violent le droit d'accès à
l'information
j'aurais qu'il nous reste cinq minutes
un con qu'on termine sur le mévente ul
je ne sais pas s'il faut y croire
fragilisation du pouvoir de vladimir
poutine christian ma carrière je me
tourne vers vous il ya eu deux appels à
la destitution qui ont été signés publié
par des par des hommes politiques locaux
à saint pétersbourg et à moscou
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça pèse qui
sont ils voient en quelle que soit alors
ils ne sont pas forcément très pro
éminent l'espace est ce qu'on appelle
des députés municipaux ça s'appelle
comme ça de deux quartiers le quartier
le monde sauf à moscou et notre quartier
à saint pétersbourg c'est donc très
limité mais c'est courageux et ça moi je
vous conte contenterez de constater un
fait restons très factuelle ça ne se
serait jamais produit à trois mois voilà
il aurait pas osé non non et là ça se
produit il ya d'autres faits aussi qui
n'ont rien à voir les uns avec les
autres mais si on met tout sur la table
par exemple l'atroce assassinat de la
fille de alexandre douguine l'idéologue
du kremlin les dialogues personnel de
poutine dont l'étoile avait quand même
pas rien
c'est pas un très bon signe donc qu'est
ce qu'on peut en déduire raisonnablement
et sans se perdre en conjectures sur
l'avenir de la lumière poutine qui reste
quand même très populaire et la période
de tension et et d'opérations spéciales
encore une fois puis séchés pas de
guerre fait que beaucoup de russes le
soutiennent et demande même qu'ils
soient plus dur plus ferme et plus
sévères donc c'est pas dans ce contexte
là qu'on peut imaginer qu'il soit
détrôné mais tout de même ce qu'on peut
dire c'est qu'il y à des tensions dans
le système au niveau certainement le
plus élevé et je parlais tout à l'heure
des généraux il ya beaucoup de cercles
nationalistes qui demandent des
sanctions contre les généraux qui
demande un durcissement du régime ça
n'est pas bon signe mais
incontestablement il ya des craquements
et détention
il faut voir ce que ça peut donner le
plus probable mon avis aux ce qu'il vaut
mais je le donne quand même c'est qu'on
arrive à un état de lassitude de
l'opinion un peu comme à la période
soviétique c'est pas du tout une
contestation de poutine je n'y crois pas
je crois pas une cotation beauty mais je
crois une espèce de détachement de
l'opinion par rapport à cette guerre
encore une fois cette opération spéciale
qui laisserait le pouvoir seul face à
l'éventuelle l'éventuelle débâcle ou
déconvenue militaire et ça ça pourrait
provoquer quelque chose patricia
allemonière mêmes questions sur le
l'effritement mais min du pouvoir de
vladimir poutine non effectivement je
partage l'idée comme quoi ces deux
personnages afin qu'un entouré de deux
autres un d'ailleurs d'autres élus ont
envoyé ces de ces deux missives en
quelque sorte passé comme la première
fois il ya eu des pétitions il ya eu
déjà de par le passé un des pétitions
des documents qui ont circulé mais
jamais une telle une telle demande ce
qui est très intéressant effectivement
c'est des extrémistes nationalistes qui
commencent à hausser le ton en
particulier celui qui avait été l'homme
de la conquête du donbass dans la en
1900 en 2004 en 2014-15 est donc lui
aussi ses élèves il demanda durcissement
dole alors on a deux une fracture qui
s'opère avec une partie qui demandent
des durcissements les plus nationalistes
les plus durs et une autre finalement
qui lentement se détache mais je ne
pense pas que vladimir poutine par
exemple se séparent immédiatement de son
ministre la défense ne s'est pas
l'habitude de l'homme de sous la
pression de se séparer de son ministre
d'autant qu'ils sont très amies
peut-être le fera t-il mais pas dans
l'urgence merci beaucoup merci à tous
les trois d'avoir participé à ce premier
débat